social summit the five speakers will
first give two introductory remarks and
after that take a few questions now
without further ado I first invite the
President of the European Council don't
risk to take the floor thank you good
afternoon
let me start by thanking the social
partner for today's good and
constructive discussions the social
farmer takes place at the critical time
for the brexit talks
unfortunately the report on the state of
the negotiations that I got from Michel
Barnier today as well as yesterday's
debate in the House of Commons give me
no grounds for optimism before
tomorrow's European Council on brexit
and if I shoot the only source of hope
for a deal for now if the good will and
determination on both sides however for
a breakthrough to take place besides the
good will we need new facts tomorrow I
am going to ask Prime Minister may
whether she has concrete proposals on
how to break the impasse only such
proposals can determine if a
breakthrough is possible while working
on the break the do we also need to make
sure that we are prepared in case an
agreement is not possible or in case it
is rejected therefore tomorrow leaders
will discuss how to step up our
preparations for a No Deal scenario but
as I have already stressed the fact that
we are preparing for another scenario
must not under any circumstances lead us
away from making every effort to reach
the best agreement possible for all
sides among other things the European
Council will also debate internal
security
the latest cyberattack against the
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons in The Hague at a time
when it was
investigating the Salisbury poisoning
shows what new threats we are facing
therefore I will propose actions to the
leaders it will strengthen our
resilience and resolve at this time they
you got ready for all possible
cybersecurity risks
the economy is another area where he
wants to be more resilient good progress
in reinforcing the economic and monetary
union by December it's still possible
even if the tensions among members of
the euro area are greater today than
they were in June therefore the euro
summit will discuss how to ensure that
we have further progress in reforming
the EMU by the end of the year for many
of the issues discussed during the
social ferment including migration and
security investments EMU digital
innovation the you budget is key as
social partners notice today the EU
budget is also our best lever for
promoting social and economic
convergence that is a very important
reason why the ongoing mff discussions
must accelerate and that is why I will
give special prominence to the MFF at
the December European Council before
concluding I want to recall that today
is the first anniversary of the murder
of Daphne coruña Galicia
since then other journalists have been
murdered also in Europe and today we are
all troubled by reports of the killing
of the Saudi journalist Jamal hisagi and
I am absolutely convinced that without a
free press our societies will not be
free this is why I called for a full
investigation to establish what happened
and to hold those responsible to account
the violence against journalists has to
stop thank you
thank you are now in white Austria's
federal Chancellor Sebastian course will
take you from
to get a dominant en ladies and
gentlemen Donald Tusk and D
representatives from the social partners
and workers and employers I would like
to express my thanks for the very good
exchange that we have today I think all
of those involved and agreed in the
goals which him we have and that
employers and workers recognize that the
European Union has to be competitive
that's the only way that we can create
jobs ensure welfare and be able to fund
our social and States in order to remain
competitive there are two decisive
issues Donald Tusk as referred to breaks
it and I think we all have an interest
and ensuring that they and we do not end
up with an heartbreaks it that there
should be an orderly Economic
Cooperation following the departure of
the UK from the European Union anything
else would be damaging both for the UK
and for the European Union we recognize
that the impacts of negotiations are
challenging and we are supporting Michel
Barnier not just in his negotiations but
also in his approach that should take
the time which is needed I think whether
the negotiations and concluded earlier
or later and it's not material it's a
question of ensuring that the LIA
concluded successfully and the solution
is fun too and Northern Ireland issue
and and something else to ensure that
Tim the European Union remains
competitive digitization digitization is
radically changing the labour market but
also the way in which we train in which
we are educated and we learn further we
have the digital
market strategy which has been the
object of progress which we welcome
Donald Tusk has also referred to the MFF
the budget for the European Union and
will of course point the way forward
that we hope that it will show strength
and focus on innovation because only if
the European Union is innovative can we
remain competitive and then thirdly M
priority has to be given to fair
taxation major Internet giants are
currently not being taxed fairly in
Europe and we therefore would like to
see an EU digital tax for Giants of the
internet because if SMEs and large
European businesses as well have to pay
taxes the same thing should apply to the
major players in the internet and from
the US or Asia and then finally we can
only be competitive remain competitive
if we work together with our partners
across the globe and in this context I'm
very pleased that we will be having an
EU ASEAN summit this week which will be
looking at the economy and cooperation
and then there will be an EU Africa
summit in Vienna in December as well for
the euro and social dialogue Baltistan
prof skis good afternoon
let me first thank president tusk
Chancellor courts and social partners
for a very good discussions we had today
today's tripartite social summit helped
us to shed some light on how the digital
revolution will affect our social and
employment policies and how European
pillar of social rights and our
ambitious proposal for the post-2020 EU
budget will help us tackle the economic
and social challenges at stake the new
multi-annual financial framework also
provides the right framework
support as a digitalization and to the
capacity for social dialogue
digitization can have a positive
employment impact especially if it's a
component by dynamic industrial policy
and a favorable business environment but
it must be complemented by reforms that
strengthen the resilience and
adaptability of the labor market change
is inevitable and we will have to
prepare for it thankfully we now have a
European pillar of social rights as a
guide for this the pillar is important
to get the convergence back to full
speed to prepare our people our
companies for the future of work and the
next mff will give us a means necessary
to support these transitions today's a
European social partners announced their
agreement on a joint work programme for
the next year's this is an excellent
sign of cooperation from the European
Commission side we remain committed to
continuous dialogue with social partners
and to achieve tangible results for
European citizens thank you very much
thank you very much now turning to the
social partners I first invite the
secretary-general of the European trade
union confederation me to look at his
insignia taken from thank you very much
I would also like to thank Chancellor
cool the president to the European
Commission and also our colleagues from
the employer side for the very good
cooperation in discussion we had today
we are of course very highly concerned
and we share this concern with President
to score a guard in the situation on
brexit we have even delivered a common
position as social partners at the
European and also British level
regarding what's going to happen and we
are very concerned that a bad deal or a
No Deal situation will really affect
negatively the interest of both
companies and workers in the European
Union and also in the United Kingdom
that's why we really appeal all the
institutions involved in this
negotiation starting with the British
government to try their best to fix the
situation by respecting the peace
process in Ireland the interest of
Irish people on both sides of the border
but at the same time also the interest
of companies and workers in the United
Kingdom at itself and also in the
European Union a transition agreement is
absolutely needed whatever will be the
scenario in front of us after the
negotiations and we need to make sure
that the single market integrity is
preserved together with the interest of
the people we represent then regarding
the specific discussion we had in the
meeting today there are three points
that for us or are of importance the
first one is that we really we are
really pleased to hear from the Austrian
government that is running the
presidency at the moment that all the
efforts will be put in place to make
sure that the pending legislative
initiatives in the social fields
including the establishment of a
European level authority will be
finalized as much as possible during the
austrian presidency before the end of
the year this is really an important
commitment on which we will guarantee
that there will be a fundamental
contribution and support from the trade
unions for sure we think that delivering
on the social pillar the European pillar
of social rights is essential before the
election to make sure that we can
represent and reestablish proper social
cohesion and also job creation in the
European Union then there is a second
topic that is also crucial for us that
is approval of the new multi-annual
financial framework we would like to
avoid a situation very similar to the
one we faced seven years ago that the
MFF the new budget is not approved on
time before the elections this will lead
to an incredible gap in terms of
financing for companies for workers for
Member States and this will be a
disaster especially in a moment like
this that we have a slight recovery this
will kill the recovery
unfortunately immediately so it's really
important that the Member States take a
commitment in Council to go for an
approval of the FF m FF and of course
then we have a really important concerns
regarding the social part of it we need
to have proper funding for job creation
to address the unemployment with
face in the european union we need to
have proper and proper funding for a
containing a just transition when it
comes to climate change and
digitalization and automation effects on
the labour market and we need also to
reinforce social partnership between the
MFF and particularly the ESF plus and
finally last but not least the European
social partners are delivering a new war
program we have still some elements to
be fixed in there because we need to
consult with our constituency but the
word program is there it's really an
important sign that social dialogue can
deliver but in this respect we need also
the help of institutions because social
dialogue is something that can happen if
there is a good and positive and
proactive environment around it
and in this respect is important that
Member States governments and the
European Commission el social partners
in delivering proper social dialogue and
properly industrial relations at all
levels there is still poor
implementation unfortunately in some
Member States the ALP that comes from
the council and from the presidency the
Austrian presidency now will also be
uncommon presidency presidencies will be
essential to reinforce the role of
social partners if social partners are
earth they can really bring an important
contribution for sustainable growth for
upward convergence to address social
dumping and abuses and also last but not
least for integration of migrants thank
you very much thank you very much
finally the president of business Europe
Pierre legatus hello yes very happy to
be with you for the first time always I
would like to say that the next two days
are crucial meetings with the European
Council meeting with the you twist 227
submit on brexit and with the euro area
submit I would like to say that voting
first of all a message on Brigitte again
all right to say that holding a chaotic
breaks it is a top priority for the
business community I represent and we
are extremely concerned about the lack
of progress in negotiations
unfortunately for the time being a cliff
edge see now you cannot be
excluded the 30th of March 2009 at 19 is
approaching very fast and negotiated
negotiators are still discussing
critical points the draft withdraw our
agreement force is a status cool like
transition with the UK staying in the
single market and custom unions during
the that period therefore it is
absolutely essential to finalize it in
time to load time for ratification in
the U on one side and in UK on the other
side it is in everyone's interest to
have a smooth transition to the future
from Iraq that we govern EU UK
relationships second topic is migration
and this is a very sensitive issue on
the agenda of the European Council
tomorrow the debate in cyborg showed
agreement on the goal of stemming
tackling illegal migration by
strengthening the external borders of
the European Union as well as
cooperation with third countries the
proposal for strengthen European border
and coast guard was also generally
well-received by the business community
also some issues still need to be
clarified us move away from other crisis
management solutions and build a
coordinated European solution to better
manage migration and paved the way to
returning to a normal functioning of
free movement in the Schengen area my
first my last point will be about the
economy and EMA the European economy has
been growing at a good pace and
unemployment is back and better at
pre-crisis level reducing levels of
poverty
this is excellent news and shows that
the reform efforts are paying off
however this window of opportunities
will not last forever business Europe's
members expect the recovery to continue
but at a lower rate than the 12 months
ago and they are downside risk linked to
political uncertainty and rising
protectionism
furthermore skill shortages and
mismatches am a rising concern for
employers and amid growth even in member
states
with relatively high unemployment
efforts to further to further strengthen
our economic and monetary union need to
be seen if significantly stepped up if
we are to fix the roof of the european
economic house while the Sun is still
shining we have just made a survey among
our members our business Europe members
on strengths the weaknesses the
opportunities and the risks of the
European Union that was quite
interesting and the answers from the
members show that European companies
company European business are very
positive about the benefits of a single
market of the euro and on the common
trade policy and don't you just take
about Europe and they are deeply
concerned about nationalist tendencies
that could undermine the European
project and the fundamental freedoms
which are the basis of our prosperity
and we had I would like to hide the fact
that as the Austrian Chancellor has said
we need to stay competitive that's the
first key elements in a world of
mutation and second thing digitalization
is so important it's a risk if we don't
do anything if we don't anticipate
anything but it's a big opportunity for
Europe to be still even more competitive
and more attractive thank you very much
thank you very much I now open the floor
for your questions and we'll start with
the gentlemen here in the second row yes
thank you it's Adam Fleming from the BBC
so I'll ask about brexit to the social
partners I mean how many jobs would be
lost in the event of an Odile brexit and
to President tusk you've called for
concrete proposals from mrs. may
proposals on what and if those proposals
aren't forthcoming what happens and is
there going to be a summit in November
or not well many jobs but it's better
not to evoke I mean these kind of
figures I mean let's try to be moderate
in this respect for sure there will be
relevant and negative economic
consequences because you know that in
the relevant industrial but also service
those products cross the border
six seven eight times I mean before
finalizing a final product that then is
sold out I mean in two markets and
blocking the border with a No Deal will
create incredible troubles for the
companies and the workers that are
employed in this in this sector so we
are really worried in this respect it's
better not to make a provision swimming
and and outlooks I mean about the number
of jobs but for sure we need to try to
avoid I mean the cliff H yes I think
that's how the companies and visas are
concerned I mean it can be a lose-lose
scenario you know because we are losing
the fief of six worldwide economy so
that's big engine leaving leading Europe
and of course we need more business we
need more growth we need trade
agreements and we don't need people
leaving Europe so I think I don't know
how many jobs we will lose on each part
of the channel but which is Sir if we
are the harbor's it is going to be very
complicated for both of us for the UK
economy on one side and for the European
economy I have nothing new to add in
fact everything is clear I mean the
problem it's clear it's still the Irish
question and and the problem of the
border between Ireland and Northern
Ireland and so-called backstop it looks
like a new version of the god you're not
[Music]
unfortunately I can't see a new version
of Alexander the Great as you know not
so easy to find this kind of creative
leader if it's for the leaders to decide
if we need an extraordinary summit in
November or not for me it's absolutely
clear that we are logistically well of
course we are ready but for what we need
also the feeling that that we are at
least close to a real breakthrough
positive breakthrough because what we
need today is to finalize our
negotiations if you know the clock is
ticking and and the five I hope that
tomorrow Prime Minister may will present
something something creative enough to
do to solve this this impasse
thank you and the next question goes to
the gentlemen also pitiful it's Austrian
television ORF president tusk and
Chancellor Coates is a No Deal breaks it
now you're number one working assumption
as things stand now is that the most
likely scenario in your ass it's a
question of our responsibility not our
prediction for sure not our plan I mean
for sure that No Deal scenario is more
likely than ever before but it doesn't
mean that that it becomes our political
priority quite the opposite
because the situation is as tricky as if
it is today we need to prepare also this
ourselves for this black spinel but I
still believe it's not only how but also
I think of a rational assessment that we
are able to find a better solution than
no deal scenario not a lot to add I
think we will work all together hard to
avoid the heartbreak seat because it's
not a good scenario no not for
the UK and also not for the eu27 and I'm
still optimistic thank you and we go to
the gentleman behind yes mr. Emmett
thank you rhetorical Italian radio since
president getas spoke about the economic
situation downside risk political in
Sirte t's president tools do you think
it's realistic to make progress on the
eurozone reform when a government the
Italian one is challenging European
rules European institution the markets
and do you fear a new euro crisis
because of of Italy and if I made to
president Dombrowski's when will you
send the first letter to the Italian
government and could you enlighten are
you asking to them to avoid the negative
opinion at the end of the month
thank you if I mentioned of just a month
ago of course I hope that positive
progress is still possible and this is
why I decided to organize this euro
summit and of course it's we have to be
realistic and and Frank I'm absolutely
aware that the atmosphere is more tricky
than in June but I think it we can use
time before December to clarify the
position of some Member States and our
goal remains I mean we want to have a
very visible progress in in December
well as regards on a second part of the
question
well we have received Italy's drug
budgetary plans as many other budgetary
plans yesterday we are currently
assessing and normally we expect if we
require additional information from
Member State we normally would request
it within a week and normally if we
decide to move for scenario of
requesting updated drug budgetary plan
that has to be done I was in two weeks
well on Commission's opinion we already
had exchange of letters with Italian
authorities and Italian authorities
brought us a letter informing about the
change of previously communicated fiscal
targets including the target of 2.4
percent of GDP deficit next year and a
commission already gave its assessment
that prima fossae it looks like
significant deviation from the
adjustment path towards a medium-term
budgetary objectives or significant
deviation from the EU fiscal rules and
asked the Italian government to do
necessary adjustments to the draft
budgetary plan well now we will be
coming already
once we will finalize our assessment
with a formal opinion I think what we
need today a respectful dialogue between
the Commission and Italy thank you and
take one final question the lady in the
first room
Marian Khan from the Financial Times a
question to Donald Tusk you said that
you want to raise them a to come up with
concrete solutions is there any onus on
the EU to think creatively about how to
break this impasse - and you mentioned
Alexander the great figures Alexander's
the first name of Boris Johnson is he a
figure that the EU is looking at to
rescue these negotiations and are you
even thinking about the next government
after two
amazed and the question to Chancellor
cuts yesterday you said that the sort of
pause in negotiations was more of a
tactic rather than a problem and that
Northern Ireland wasn't necessarily a
real sticking point it was just part of
the drama of negotiations having
listened to mr. tusk do you still think
it's a tactic and if it is is it working
okay my question is the easier one so I
can probably start well not a tactic of
the EU but probably a tactic of UK I
think that the suggestions
Michelle pan game made on the border
issue are quite good and listening to
what he said during the Salzburg meeting
I think that there is a way to find the
de ideas on the table to find to find a
way to deal with the question of the
border but of course there are also
other issues like the future
relationship the question of a single
market or business cooperation between
the UK and EU 27 and these are also
quite difficult questions but I think if
both sides want there is a chance to
find an agreement the question
afterwards will be if there is a
majority for this agreement in the
British Parliament and also in the
European Parliament because this is as
important as the question if we can find
a way to deal with Theresa May or not to
compare both Johnson - to Alexander the
Great as a sort of exaggeration I think
that it's because my private opinion and
it's both sides are responsible for for
for this possible still possible
breakthrough of course but mmm when it
comes to this very context I mean
backstop we need I think something fresh
in
in our discussions and to be very clear
because I've heard some comments
sometimes very dramatic comments one of
the author is also Boris Johnson that
they you want to annex eight
economically not an island and or to
split the UK it's of course it's not the
truth it's objectively this is a very
difficult and complicated issue in fact
if it is a kind of unfortunately natural
and automatic result of the brexit
decision I mean the the question of of
the Irish border and this is why we need
something very creative to - - you know
at the same time to protect our values
to protect single market and at the same
time to respect fully respect UK with
mmm and its sovereignty
it's from it's clear the goal is must be
clear for all of us but for this we need
maybe a new method of thinking because
yeah the objective is Isis or something
really difficult thank you this
concludes the first conference